the first trip to hungary by a french
president in 14 years and at the prime
minister's office the visitor didn't shy
away from the big challenge that's
causing ongoing tensions in europe
i think that what europe has gone
through in recent weeks and we'll be
talking about this in particular with
our polish colleagues allows us to
reconsider a common organization
how to better prevent migrant flows and
protect our external borders and find
ways and means of a more efficient
cooperation between europeans on this
matter
victor orban's government is challenging
a ruling by the european court of
justice that hungary broke eu law by
deporting refugees over the border into
serbia last week the constitutional
court here ruled the government could
apply its own measures but sidestepped
the issue of whether eu law had primacy
over hungarian law that's an issue
that's already created a clash between
brussels and poland macron also joined a
meeting of the so-called visigrad group
the polish prime minister along with his
hungarian czech and slovak counterparts
earlier macron met leaders of the
opposition alliance that's challenging
orban in next year's elections
but despite clear concerns macron and
other leaders have about issues such as
lgbt rights in hungary and media freedom
there was agreement on what orban calls
strategic autonomy
in our opinion there is no autonomy
without a european defense industry or
without our own energy capability or
rather without nuclear energy and
there's no autonomy without
self-sufficiency in agriculture
both leaders have made it clear that
they don't see eye to eye on a variety
of issues but for president macron this
was really a chance to show the european
union that when his country takes over
the rotating presidency in january he'll
be able to handle internal disputes
no big breakthroughs then but a signal
the eu should be able to discuss the
toughest issues without acrimony how far
that's possible in the new year is far
from clear nadim baba al-jazeera
budapest